Xin quyền đang vi hào của nộng em 2 tháng 2 bàn hành cạnh báo của mùa giấc cầm sau khi bán hiện nhiều con qua,
chếm mất thường và hình đã bàn gà.
Các mô bình phần người xin nghiệm tại phòng tin nghiệp ở bố bán cho biết kết qua giung tình về viero của mùa giấc cầm nộn bước cao.
Cái sao đó lỗ tụi và chính quyền để phương đại trên khá của bệnh pháp tình tất.
Gồm thu gòn và sự lý xa chim ăn quan tăng cường giảm xác chim, mong giả á và kìm chạc chẳng chạy giấc cầm lương cầm,
giảm, mong em viero gà lấy lần.
Giờ chức ý để cầm báo của mùa giấc cầm chủ yếu lây ở chim,
sau trong những trường hợp hiếm có thể truyền sang người qua kết xuất chức tiếp và chim bắt,
chim chết phòng mô chổ hồ nhóm,
trường trường hợp ngồi thường xuất hiện sau 2 đến tấm ngày nhiều viero tự sốt,
hỏa để khó thơ, trường hợp nằm có thể gây viên 4 và 4 hấp.
Nãy chức trách quyền gặm người dân tránh tiếp xuất và chim chết,
hạm chế đến trở chim sống, mào đàn bệ sinh càng nhân và chiếc giục ra cầm đàn đầu chim kí.
Vào mì hà cho biến sẽ tiếp tục xanh nghiệm dễn rộng và ám giộng của biển pháp ăn toàn sinh hợp để báo vệ sự khỏe cộm đông.